fans of Luthor have had it pretty rough
after waiting five years for the fifth
season the entire experience was over in
just four episodes however even with the
short length of season five comes a lot
to unpack from it throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the show's final
episode and what could be happening in
season six there will of course be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the outcome of
season 5 then I highly suggest that you
turn off now but without the way I'm
definition and welcome to the channel
where I ruin it so you don't have to we
pick up where the last episode left off
with the aftermath of Benny Silver's
death Jeremy is still on the loose and
is continuing his murder spree after his
and Vivian's lair was discovered he's
killed a man hung him over a bridge in
this place to mask up his face on his
head in what seems like a Hannibal
Lecter costume party in the episode we
learn that Jeremy kept a confessional
book which was apparently his only
outlet as Vivian made him keep his
crimes secret in interrogation she
initially denies the crimes but the
truth all comes out in the end with her
being implicated in the murders as an
accomplice the violence continues when
Jeremy arrives at the house of the
schoolteacher whose pupil he murdered in
the first episode he lures a plumber and
sex worker there after using the house
as his home at the station Luther
correctly figured out that Jeremy would
be using house as part of his happy
family's fantasy he eventually traces
her down and upon arriving there with
Halliday they discovered that there are
six corpses all with masks of Jeremy's
face on them one of these corpses turns
out to be Jeremy in hiding and he uses
this opportunity to rush holiday Luther
however gets the better of him though
and handcuffs him to a radiator holiday
then tells Luther that she has informed
Schneck of his whereabouts and that he
has only a few minutes to escape this is
when the other plot of the episode comes
to fruition which involves the weird
relationship between Alison
throughout the episode Luther and Alice
had a couple of close calls but after
the situation with Cornelius she felt
betrayed and this drugged the climax of
the finale just as Luther is about to
flee Alice appears and shoots Halliday
in order to set him up she shoots him in
the shoulder and runs which forces
Luther to chase her into a building site
using the trail of blood police are able
to track them but it's all just too
little too late in the finale
Alex shoots Luther again and slashes him
across the face when he tries to arrest
her she admits that she loves him but
knows that he doesn't understand love or
have the capability for it pretending to
be out of ammo she lures him out and
just as she is about to shoot him again
he lunges at it which leads to her
falling off some scaffolding Luther
tries to save her but she forces his
hand literally by slicing it which
causes him to let her go leading to her
death she knew there was no escape from
it and that suicide was the only way to
fully get revenge Luther is then
arrested and he seems pretty bang to
rights especially with Alice warning
mark after Luther earlier in the episode
her death will now hold a lot of weight
in his conviction and it seems very
unclear whether he will be able to get
out of this one but there is some
exciting news for the character coming
down the line in a recent interview with
the Radio Times idris elba stated that I
don't think we're going to do too many
TV versions of it I think the next step
is to make a film the season has the
film very much in its sight in regards
to season 6 he then stated we've got
Scott an idea for a film and I'm not
allowed to say too much but what I can
say is that this season very much has
the film in its sights if there is a
film then it will somehow be connected
into this season this is of course
amazing news and Idris is no stranger to
the big screen obviously I'm sure
everyone will be excited to see this
come to fruition
including me I definitely love to hear
your thoughts on whether you think there
will be a film and what you'd hope to
see in a as well as if you liked the
fifth season if you enjoy this video
then please like it and check out my
breakdown of this week's other BBC event
the Doctor Who resolution which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to Definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best
next time take care peace